the court condemns you to life
imprisonment that verdict was handed by
a court in dakar in 2016
after a year of trial for alleged crimes
against humanity
a graduate in political science from a
french university hussein habre was the
commander of a rebel group in northern
chad when he deposed gokoniwadai to take
over as president in 1982.
during his eight years in power he ruled
chad with an iron fist and was accused
of ordering the killings of his
political opponents an estimated 40 000
people died at the hands of his security
forces a human rights lawyer defending
the victims said habre was a pitiless
dictator who slaughtered his own people
burned down entire villages sent women
to serve as sex slaves for his soldiers
critics say during the time he committed
those atrocities he was enjoying close
ties with and support from both france
and the united states
abre was at war with america's arch
enemy in north africa at the time libyan
leader ammar qaddafi
president ronald reagan received habre
in the white house in 1987. president
habry emphasized that his government
is committed to building a better life
for the chadian people
habrev fled to senegal following a coup
in 1990 an arrest warrant was issued
against him in 2005 after some of his
victims filed a suit against him senegal
was reluctant to try him but habre was
arrested in 2013
after an intervention by the african
union he strongly objected to his trial
and the life term awarded to him
he was the first former african head of
state to be tried and convicted on
african soil through an african-led
legal process senegalese prison
officials say heisei and habre died on
tuesday after a cov19 infection